earlier this morning we spoke to former
Secretary of State Condoleezza Rice
about Israel's claim and how the US
should respond we asked her if she's
seen any evidence that Iran has violated
that 2015 accord first of all the reason
that we have been so concerned about
Iran is that we know that they lie and
cheat about their nuclear weapons
programs and they've done that going
back into the early 2000s I haven't seen
the entire dossier but I suspect that it
simply reinforces what we've always
known that the Iranians were secretly
developing nuclear weapons at secret
sites
it doesn't perhaps speak to the 2015
agreement except in the following way
you have to worry about verification
with the Iranians and the verification
measures in the 2015 agreement were not
very strong they had for instance long
periods of notification long periods of
dispute resolution and so when you know
that a country lies about its nuclear
weapons a verification regime that is
weak it's a really problematic got
various members of the Trump
administration testified publicly to
Congress that there is no proof that
Iran is violating the 2015 Accord what
is the damage if President Trump
withdraws from that of course well let
me say Norah I wouldn't have signed this
agreement to begin with I've said that
before I think it was a weak agreement
particularly on verification it allows
Iran to break out after a specific
period of time I probably would have
stayed in for Alliance management
reasons more than anything else but I
don't think that it's the end of the
world if the administration leaves the
agreement now I'm hoping that the
conversations the president has had for
instance with president McComb of France
would suggest that we could approve the
agreement and perhaps if that could be
done this could go but the
administration's been worried about this
agreement from the very beginning and
and there's reason to be worried about
this agreement and we'll bring you more
of our conversation with secretary rice
in our next hour she'll reflect on her
new book political risk plus president
Trump's upcoming summit with North
Korean dictator Kim jong-un